british prime minister boris johnson has
withstood a challenge to his
conservative party leadership with an
election three years away can he regain
mp's trust and perhaps more importantly
that of the british people this is
inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i am hashem
ahalbala the uk prime minister says it's
time to move on from questions about his
leadership
boris johnson survived a confidence vote
within his own party on monday
calling the outcome convincing and a
decisive result
but the scale of the rebellion means
some government ministers and aides
voted against johnson in the secret
ballot while supporting him
in public
not since marguerita's leadership
challenge in 1990 has there been such a
close vote
even though he survived this round it's
definitely raising doubts about boris
johnson's future
211 conservative mps voted to support
the prime minister while 148 voted
against him that means 40 percent of
johnson's colleagues chose not to back
him al jazeera's paul brennan reports
from london
a victory for the prime minister but far
from convincingly the vote in favour
uh of having confidence in boris
johnson's theater was 211 votes and the
vote against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
a raucous reaction from boris johnson's
supporters but there's no disguising the
enormity of the 148 mps who voted
against their own leader
i think it's a convincing
result a decisive result on what it what
it means is that as uh
as a government we can move on and focus
on the stuff that i think really matters
to people
mr speaker recent feverish speculation
about boris johnson's political future
have been relegated somewhat by last
week's four-day national holiday in
honor of the queen's platinum jubilee
but the public booing which greeted the
prime minister at friday's service of
thanksgiving for the queen was an
ominous indicator
a random sample of london commuters
confirms a certain degree of public
disillusionment i thought that was so
telling that actually that he got booed
i think that was almost like that felt
like a turning point to me actually
despite securing a solid 80 seat
majority in the general election just
two and a half years ago boris johnson
has endured months of controversy and
criticism which have steadily undermined
his authority
chief among them the partygate saga
where johnson and many of his staff were
found to have flouted covet lockdown
rules at downing street gatherings
johnson became the first pm judge to
have broken the law while in office the
official inquiry into those events
criticized a lack of leadership
the british public are fed up
fed up with a prime minister who
promises big but never delivers
fed up with a prime minister who's
presided over a culture of lies and law
breaking at the heart of government
fed up with a prime minister who is
utterly unfit for the great office that
he holds it's a victory for boris
johnson but hardly a ringing endorsement
of him and his leadership one
commentator on monday said johnson's
appeal within the party was a mile wide
but just an inch deep and so it seems
johnson himself will undoubtedly battle
on fighting tooth and nail to retain his
grip on power but his options are
rapidly dwindling
the current rules mean it will be at
least 12 months before a new confidence
vote can be called but questions about
the prime minister's judgment and
credibility remain and precedent shows
that surviving a confidence vote often
represents only a stay of execution for
tory leaders rather than a full reprieve
paul brennan al jazeera westminster
let's bring in our guests in london
kevin craig is ceo and founder of plmr
communications in edinburgh ross greer
is scottish green party politician and
member of the scottish parliament in
london anna mendoza is executive
director of the henry jackson society
welcome to the program kevin
for prime minister
he wants the people to turn the chapter
move on do you see it that same way
i think even somebody who
tries to be as politically neutral as
possible in this country
has to say now it's going to be very
difficult for the prime minister to move
on he may have won the vote of
confidence last night about among his
own mps but look at this statistic in
the house of commons in the british
parliament
211
of the 650 mps
think that the prime minister is the
right man to lead the country
and i know you can say a win by one vote
is a win but last night was a
historically exceptionally low level of
support for a sitting conservative mp
and i think in reality with all these
challenges coming ahead the environment
the cost of living the conflict in
ukraine
um it it is going to be very difficult
for boris johnson who is a great
political survivor
to see this through and we have two
big moments of danger coming up in the
next month in britain for him
number one
in late june two parliamentary
by-elections
if he loses both of those in particular
one where the liberal democrats the
who are uh one of the top five parties
in this country like the greens if he
loses that he's in severe trouble and we
have a house of commons privileges
committee
publicly
looking into whether or not the prime
minister lied to the house of commons so
yes
he won last night technically and in
arithmet arithmetic terms but this is
not over
ross the opposition came out critical of
the outcome of the vote and also the
legacy of mr johnson do you are you one
of those who think that his days are
numbered
it's very clear that when three quarters
of his back bench mps backbench tory mps
say they have no confidence in him it's
time to go boris johnson only survived
the vote of confidence because of the
payroll vote the large number of tory
mps who are ministers junior ministers
parliamentary secretaries who are part
of the government when you've lost
control of three quarters of your own
backbench parliamentary party never mind
the rest of the country clearly your
days are numbered theresa may survive
the vote of no confidence with a larger
margin than this and was still gone
within a few months it's not just about
the fact that boris johnson and all of
those around him broke the rules that
they were setting during coven it's the
fact that he lied about it this whole
episode shows up one of the traits that
most people in the uk always knew about
boris johnson and people of his class
that they think they can get away with
anything because so much of their life
has been spent not having to deal with
the consequences of their own decisions
now scotland's obviously in a different
place
scotland never had confidence in boris
johnson in the first place his party
have never won an election here you have
to go back to the 50s for the
predecessor party to have won one but
it's quite quite clear across the uk
there is absolutely no trust in this
prime minister and when you've got a
cost of living crisis a war on the
european continent a climate emergency
and so much still deeply wrong with our
economy you need politicians you need
leaders who you can trust boris johnson
has used that all up he quite clearly
lied not just to parliament but to the
public as well
alan
do you see boris johnson bouncing back
in the near future
well i think um he's going to need to
bounce back if he's going to survive
that's the reality of this yes he did
secure a victory it was a victory
ultimately you know you could have gone
with that backdrop that your previous
guests uh have uh set out um you might
have expected him to lose that vote he
didn't he held on um i also think it's
maybe a mistake to think if certainly
his back benches voting against him
there might be others you know ambitious
people you know maneuvering within the
uh the cabinet itself to look at this
but take it aside for a second he's won
the vote maybe it wasn't you know a
convincing as convincing a victory as he
would have liked he now has a brief
period of time when he can reset or
attempt to reset the agenda and the
reality is he needs to do this very
quickly he does have a a problem with
two by-elections coming up
and we'll see how the conservatives
doing that but i would expect if he
really wants to uh you know kind of stay
in this job i would expect there to be a
reshuffle uh of his government and i'd
expect there to be a series of um policy
launches to show that he is leading once
again i think part of the reason he's
been in trouble is because there's a
sense of government has been a little
bit injured now maybe events have
contributed to that now he needs to get
a handle on that very quickly um and if
he can i i think he it is possible he
could turn this around simply because um
he has a remarkable ability to get out
of you know positions others might not
manage to kevin judging from the results
of the confidence vote
is he likely to be able to hold the
party together because there's
absolutely no doubt in the mind of the
people who are watching the vote
that the the the tories are more divided
than ever
yes and i'm going to make a real effort
here to be to try and be really fair to
the prime minister and try to be very
measured in what i say but
look at the reality we have now on
social media a briefing note written by
conservative mps
outlining in great detail
the flaws and all the reasons why
boris johnson makes a terrible prime
minister and once a week here in britain
we have prime minister's questions and
can you imagine how terrible it's going
to be every week
when the leader of the labour party the
leader of the snp uh the scottish
nationalist party uh in westminster they
get up and they've got an attack sheet
to really use viciously against the
prime minister
not written by people who don't vote
conservative this is written by
conservative mps and the reality is i
heard what your previous guest said and
that is one theoretical way forward but
sometimes in politics in this country
you can you can smell the way that
things are going and even though he won
last night you know it is i i cannot see
boris johnson leading the conservative
party into the next general election
i'll tell you this the labour party
certainly would love it if he did
currently
but politically in terms of political
strategy the clever thing to do for the
conservatives which they've done before
because as we all know on this show
today they're very very clever at
winning elections is to find a new
leader and then try and make the rest of
the country forget that it's actually
been the conservatives with the prime
minister since 2010. that would be the
clever thing to do that's what they'll
probably do
ross what would be the future for the
opposition i i would assume that they
would like to seize the moment but
ultimately despite all the statements
made by the opposition we're still
talking about the man who led his party
to a landslide victory in 2019
and for many still remains invincible
kevin's right that for those of us in
opposition parties boris johnson is the
perfect opponent for the scottish
independence movement he is absolutely
the perfect opponent he's everything
that we want uh people to to believe
westminster politics is and the reasons
why people in scotland should vote for
independence but even for the uk labour
party of course he's the perfect
opponent but we all still believe he
should go because that's the right thing
there should be consequences for your
actions in this country especially when
you occupy the highest office in it so
as much as yeah it would be electorally
fantastic for everyone who's got a
conservative opponent for boris johnson
to still be in place at the time of the
next election it's the right thing for
him to go now and i'm quite sure that
conservative mps will not be motivated
by doing the right thing they will be
motivated by their own self-interest
they'll be seeing the same polling that
the rest of us are that their support in
the so-called red wall across the north
of england has massively eroded their
support in core conservative areas in
the south east south of london is
massively eroded as well they'll be
looking at their own self-interest did
they really want to keep him on as the
party leader if it's going to cost them
their own seat and their own job i think
that is what's going to push more
conservative mps over the edge and i
absolutely agree he will not be the
leader of the conservative party come
the next election and he can't put an
agenda together to lead his party to
unite his party never mind to unite the
country if you think of the two most
memorable things he's done in recent
weeks one was not his it was rishi sunak
announcing a windfall tax that the
opposition had forced them into it's a
watered-down version of it but something
the opposition forced it wasn't the
conservative zone the only
conservative-made policy i can remember
from the last few weeks is their
announcement that they're bringing back
pounds announces imperial measurements
boris johnson doesn't have a governing
agenda he wants to be he's always wanted
to be prime minister he doesn't actually
want to do the job of being prime
minister we need someone who's actually
interested in doing this job at time as
critical as this alan could the economy
be his last chance to win the hearts and
minds of the british people particularly
if he manages within the upcoming months
to fix the issues of the cost of living
inflation and also the domestic energy
costs well of course that would be a
dramatic uh turnaround i i think we've
got to manage expectations on that one
in reality we're in a global situation
when it comes to the cost-living crisis
here's something being shared across the
world right now and you know maybe we'll
manage it better than other people maybe
way but i think we've got some way to
roll
on that subject before we get to the end
point but i actually want to come back
on what you know ross said there is
something to the idea that he has to now
show leadership is what i said at the
start the reality is if there is no
leadership coming forth from boris now i
do think he is sunk as the prime
minister and leader of the conservative
party his only chance of coming out of
this is going to be to put together an
agenda that firstly gives some hope to
his party that um you know their
interests and concerns are being met
secondly give some hope to the country
uh interests and concerns are being met
in that way now he's a very good vision
person and he's a very good motivator
and to give an example of that look at
the work he's done in ukraine where he's
essentially led the world on that yes of
course president biden's joined in on
that as well but if you compare where
the europeans are largely to where the
british have been boris has come out and
it's been one of his finest hours if he
can transfer that level of leadership to
the domestic agenda and it's going to
obviously be a big ask but if he can
then there is a route out of this for
him most definitely because i think
people respond to that kevin where does
it leave political life in the uk are we
likely to see more politically inviting
divisions and uh posturing among all the
political parties for a bigger say in
the near future
i think the biggest consequence of
what's happened which i think probably
all of us will agree on is the is the
uncertainty and it is a remarkable fact
to remember that in december 2019
43
43.6
of the popular vote in britain the
general election voted for the
conservative party led by boris johnson
it is an incredible story of what can
change in a very short period of time
less than three years
and yes the the there is uncertainty we
have to try and in my job to advise
clients public sector charities on
businesses on what's going to happen
next and it just now the reality is the
boris johnson agenda whatever that turns
out to be is going to be very difficult
to get through in parliament because i
go back to the fact that only 211 out of
650 british mps think he's the man for
the job so of course it's uncertain i
think you're
right if it wasn't for ukraine i think
he would have lost the vote last night
because he has done what i expect any
prime minister to have done which is led
with courage from the front but you know
it is
going to be the most incredibly volatile
and uncertain
uh time in british politics up to the
last possible date of the general
election in december 24 and that will
have implications internationally
because
you will probably see a different
set of leaders going into the general
election and a new prime minister that
that is more likely now in my opinion
ross when you look at the legacy of
boris johnson people have been talking
about his eccentric behavior but
but you know when you look at the start
of the pandemic he was late to respond
however the way he
responded later by maximizing the
vaccine drive in the country opening up
the society when most of europe was
really skeptical about that move the way
he's been handling the ukraine crisis
gives you an indication that this
someone who is going to fight until the
end for his political survival
it indicates that boris johnson will
fight for one thing and that's his own
job not for the public there were so
many steps he could have taken
throughout the pandemic that would have
saved more lives and he didn't do it
what we're seeing now is a man who's
fighting really really hard but to keep
his own job if i think of boris
johnson's legacy of his time in office
these last couple of years i think of
the 20-pound cut to universal credit
that's putting millions of families back
into crisis i think of the the
devastation to our public services
i think of the the fact that yes in the
last few months he may have shown the
kind of leadership we would expect from
any british prime minister over ukraine
but this is the leader of a conservative
party who's accepted incredibly large
donations from those very very closely
associated with vladimir putin done
nothing until recently to clean up the
huge amount of money laundering in the
city of london that finances the kremlin
and others and even now the steps
they're taking are completely inadequate
it is not good enough to only be the
kind of prime minister who's capable of
putting an effort in when your own job
is on the way the prime minister should
be putting an effort and every single
day for the people not just those who
elected them obviously for the whole
country for the planet as a whole boris
johnson doesn't do that because as i
said before he's always wanted to be
prime minister he's never actually
wanted to do the job of prime minister
and we need someone who will do that job
in a time of climate emergency and
economic crisis never mind war on our
continent we need somebody who wants to
do the job not somebody who just wants
to go down in history books is having
occupied the building alan who do you
think has the potential to take over
become the next
successor of boris johnson i'll give you
a list of names
liz trust ben wallace
richie sunak
penny
mondrand and jeremy hunt
well they've all got their own you know
kind of abilities and sort of negatives
attached to them uh by the way there are
a few others who would be upset they're
not on on your list people like madame
zahawi grant trap you know there's quite
a number of people who could quite
happily um you know make it on to be
prime minister but the question really
is at the moment um it's still boris
johnson's toulouse as such he's got this
opportunity now to come out swinging in
the way we've seen him do it before um
and i don't think it's fair to say that
he only he only sort of acts when his
job's at stake you know some of the
decisions he made uh during cable had
nothing to do with his job at state
these were big decisions for the country
decisions to push forward in certain
ways versus others in mistakes were made
but show me a country where mistakes
were not made i think what's interesting
is he's got the big calls right
in the past few years the question is on
now the biggest call of all which is
frankly the agenda for this country
going forward is he going to get that
right and this will be the test can he
come out and will he be able to speak to
people in the street as it were and say
look i know what your concerns are i
feel the same as you and this is what i
intend to do about it that's why he won
that big majority in 2019 because he was
able to address that so the question now
is can he summon up the spirit of that
once again in very difficult
circumstances and provide a winning
combination and the answer to his
premiership and whether any those others
will take over rest solely on that
question kevin now the labour party
seems to be making some gains in the in
the latest surveys but however
do you see the potential for for the
labour party to take over in the
upcoming general elections and do you
think that the public opinion is going
to be willing to move forward to a new
leadership against the backdrop of a
dysfunctional economy and it's which is
in tatters huge political problems and
you have the war in ukraine
yeah well i think uh
the labour party under kia stammer
is more uh electable and more credible
uh that at any time in many many years i
think as kier himself would say as
leader of the labour party um it was a
very very bad defeat in 2019 it was the
labour party's worst results since the
1930s
and you don't
automatically earn the right to govern
just because the other side um are in
other words messing it up that's not
enough to hope to win by default and i
think the challenge for
uh secure stammer and the labour party
is to
outline a vision of what britain looks
like under his leadership
and that job is not yet complete as he
would say but the one thing he does have
in his favor
is that people trust him more they think
he has integrity um i think that
the theory we've just heard about what
boris johnson could do is fine but i
think every piece of evidence suggests
at the moment the british public are not
listening and they don't believe boris
anymore shakir star makes his challenges
increase his personality as the public
feel it and see it and outline that
vision
for what the country is and that will be
the challenge for the green party that
my colleague here represents tonight you
know that's that's the challenge
although labour are doing much much
better than they were ross uh briefly if
you don't mind what was the problem with
boris johnson his personal behavior
or the substance of the of the legacy
itself
the substance of his time in in office
has done far far more damage to the
british public than his behavior his
behavior is shocking lying in parliament
lying to the public that's unacceptable
but this is a prime minister who's
presided over cuts to universal credit
that have put huge numbers of families
back into financial crisis at a time
where there's an existing cost of loving
crisis he's a prime minister who's
presided over more arms sales to some of
the worst human rights abusers on the
planet a government that's just greenlit
a new gas field in the north sea just a
few months after hosting the cop26
climate summit these are all decisions
that we will have to bear the
consequences of for decades and in the
case of the climate decisions for
centuries to come those are the real
pressing reasons why we need a change of
government in the uk and why i believe
scotland needs actually to leave the uk
entirely we'll have to leave it there
ross garina kevin craig ala mendoza
thank you very much indeed for the
insight
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from mihashivalvara and
the entire team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you